- Baked goods for cancer research?
Baked goods for cancer research?
It's a great cause.
Baked goods for breast cancer
research, it's a great cause.
- Brenda, people don't only
die from breast cancer.
All cancers matter, okay?
(swooshing and creaking)
- It's for my aunt.
- Yeah, I just need to buff out this spot.
- We gotta paint the whole car.
- Paint the whole car?
It's only one spot.
- If we paint one part of the car,
we gotta paint the whole car.
It all matters.
- Oh, this one's dying.
I'm gonna give it a little bit more water.
- We give each plant an
equal amount of water.
- See, I get that,
it's just that this
plant's been in the shade.
And because of where it was placed,
I think it deserves a
little bit more water.
- I'm sorry, are you saying
because this one's been in the shade,
it deserves to be on top
of all the other plants?
Is that what you're saying?
- No, no.
I'm just gonna give it
a little bit more water.
- I feel like the right side
is shorter than the left
and I'd like them to match equally.
- Ooh, if I cut one side,
I definitely have to cut the other side.
- Wait, wait, I don't
need the left side cut.
I just want them to be at equal lengths.
- I definitely cut them
both equal last time,
so maybe one of your sides just
grows faster than the other.
Let's get started.
(upbeat Russian music by Russian Paddlers)
- I'm just gonna give it more water
because racism.